now china is doubling down on its
retaliation for the u.s house speaker
nancy pelosi's visit to taiwan the trip
enraged beijing which is conducting
several days of air and naval drills
around taiwan in response
china is also suspending cooperation
with the u.s on issues including law
enforcement and climate change taiwan's
defense ministry says it fired flares to
warn of drones and unidentified aircraft
flying off its coast
tensions in the taiwan strait have put
the region on the edge
this is the first time the chinese
military drills have taken place so
close to the self-governed island
taiwan says the chinese army appears to
be practicing for an attack
chinese officials are clear on the
message they want to send
our military exercises have been
conducted in an open transparent and
professional manner and are in line with
the domestic law international law and
international practice the drills are
aimed at issuing a warning to the
perpetrators and punishing the taiwan
independence secessionist forces
china sees taiwan as a breakaway
province
and visits to the island by foreign
officials like u.s house speaker nancy
pelosi as an affront to its sovereignty
as a consequence china is now also
suspending cooperation with the us on
issues including law enforcement and
climate change
the u.s secretary of state addressed the
issue during his visit to the
philippines
which is a key stakeholder in the region
we should not hold hostage cooperation
on matters of global concern because of
differences between our two countries
others are rightly expecting us to
continue to work together on issues that
matter to the lives and livelihoods of
their people as well as our own
relations between the world's two
largest economies have nosedived in
recent days
and the consequences will likely be felt
far beyond the region
let's speak now to dw's joycely in
taipei
give us the latest on china's military
drills and taiwan's response to them
yeah chinese drones flying close to
cayman islands late at night has become
like a routine now and uh
this morning several
chinese warplanes and warships crossed
the taiwan strait median line again
the island's defense ministry said that
they believe china is simulating an
attack on taiwan's main island and it's
clear that china is trying to uh change
the status quo of the eye of the taiwan
strait according to experts and the
military exercises could become a new
normal
and meanwhile the chinese authorities
announced that they're going to conduct
live fire shooting drills for 10 days in
the southern waters of the yellow sea
that's a an area very very close to
south korea it came right after seoul
expressed objections to china's attempts
to change the status quo by force and it
is seen as sending a warning to the u.s
military base in korea and
also the
cyber attack against taiwan is ongoing
and there are a lot of like fake news
and rumors uh running wild online
taiwan's premier susan tong said they're
part of china's psychological warfare
campaign
so how is taiwan responding to all of
this
well i know some expat groups and
multinational firms have started to
discuss evacuation plans
but for
you know most of the local taiwanese
people they grew up living with china's
threat so life goes on even during the
unprecedented drills i've talked to a
lot of people on the street and most of
them don't believe there will be an
immediate war and some told me that they
feel more disgusted than scared by
china's bully and people are quite
concerned about the economic impact if
it becomes a new normal in the coming
years if china further isolates taiwan
it could disrupt taiwan's economy and
drive up inflation
so you mentioned that this could be the
new normal when we say this what are we
saying how long could this go on for
well experts uh expect that chinese war
planes and warships could uh you know
across the median line of the taiwan
strait more frequently in the coming
years and uh that could isolate uh
taiwan furthermore
okay
thank you joyce lee in taipei
you